les yeux émerveillés camille découvre sa
nouvelle main une prothèse en plastique
audois mobile quelques réglages et la
petite fille prend vite de l'assurance
comme ça tu pouvoir à venir yes et un
plaît beaucoup
bah parce que elle peut se plier le
mieux ça va changer que je pourrai
attraper les choses mais mieux et puis
ça va changer un peu la vie ap à bientôt
neuf ans camille est atteinte depuis la
naissance d'une malformation du bras
gauche
originaire de saône et loire c'est au
collège des courlis à nevers qu'elle a
pu trouvé ce moyen de dépasser le
handicap grâce à neuf élèves de 3e qui
ont réalisé le mécanisme joie comme
catch iv c'est une fin c'est merveilleux
pour nous fait un peu tout ça était
finie concret elle est contente et puis
ça fonctionne donc on est vraiment très
content d'avoir fait déterminé ce projet
à l'origine une association fournit les
plans aux fab lab de l'établissement les
élèves et leur professeur de technologie
ont ensuite travaillé depuis octobre sur
le projet on part du fichier on met à la
taille on met à l'échelle après il faut
imprimer pièce par pièce et après donc
on imprime il a fallu assembler nettoyer
chaque pièce vérifier les assemblages
câble et revoir nos avec des élastiques
qui classe parce qu'ils sont mal câblée
parce que c'est mal fait donc il a fallu
faire tout ça enfin moi j'avais jamais
toucher vraiment d'imprimantes vous
apprendra thermoformé la selle c'était
cool on a appris des trucs une aventure
technique et humaine qui ouvre de
nouvelles perspectives à camille
avec même un bonus en plus de la
prothèse les collégiennes lui ont créé
des médiateurs adapté qui lui
permettront d'apprendre la guitare
[Musique]